sois prêt à vivre l'expérience la plus merveilleuse
de ta vie je voulais faire
quelque chose le secouer avec une nouvelle
perspective ouvrir l'esprit ouais tu commences
le combat pour faire
tu as besoin de créer un autre monde le
monde optique n'est pas le
monde auditif littéraire dont j'ai besoin  pour trouver des ouvriers j'ai
besoin de trois mille dessins point
du mouvement de la boite de dialogue j'utilise
mon appareil photo recycle il a été très rapide Chut
était super humain je suis allé vendre Giggy il
fait le monstre de valeur
car ouvrez la gueule ça n'y va pas
out oui alors le changement est venu dans la tombola
Elizabeth comme un dictateur ou un chef de secte
et rassemblant son armée autour de lui et la
largeur de la portion étant libre alors Lee
Nikita ici pour le scénariser comme votre
coup d'état je pourrais ordonner que vous feriez
une superbe machine vous
-même est-ce  rêve ne change pas mon équipe juin est
probablement le plus grand film jamais
réalisé il continue de nous influencer
malgré le fait qu'il n'existe pas
nous ne pouvons pas le louer nous ne pouvons pas le regarder
Xiaomei Donnie à armer  et se sentent plus
comme s'ils étaient aversifs pour la
divinité et je vais vous dire
quelque chose c'est génial son énorme
plus grand que 2001 pourrait être fantastique
vous pouvez entendre et parfois je prends le temps de
vous remercier